or joining me now to discuss this
further as retired Air Vice Marshall
Sean Bell Sean it's great to have you
here with us just listening to that how
much weight should we put behind these
comments generally all he's doing is
reflecting what most military analysts
believe which is very difficult to see
either side winning in this summer
campaign it's interesting today's first
of April Start of spring we're expecting
the Ukraine spring offensive to start in
reality uh almost certainly they've just
had the challenge of two tanks arrived
the leper 2 tanks from the West they're
now available in Ukraine but the terrain
around is still extremely boggy and
these 65 ton tanks would much prefer to
be they're going to be much more
effective at punching holes once they're
actually on firmer terrain and that
probably won't happen until sort of May
time so although it's unlikely that
Ukraine will win uh in this summer
period the West will be hoping for
significant advances just to demonstrate
the Ukraine is capable of pushing the
Russian forces back what about the
Russian side yeah the Russian offensive
they started 11th of January and where
General grasimov took over command of
the forces in Russia 80 Days in frankly
pretty poor showing made very limited uh
progress they've squandered the one
advantage they had which was massive
Manpower on a huge Battlefield uh
casualties mainly around back moot
internal fighting the fighting goes
intensely uh going on there without
getting too much don't have the time but
around the center of back moot the
Wagner forces are making very slow
progress but outside Ukraine forces are
pushing back
um the pincers that were coming round
the side I think one of the things that
Russia desperately needs now is more
troops uh the first of April March the
start of their semi-annual recruitment
campaign for their conscripts the
problem is that technically those
conscripts shouldn't be used outside the
borders of Russia we'll wait to be see
there what they'll actually need to do
is recruit more volunteers and
reservists but they just don't have the
training capacity to deliver those
absolutely and we saw masses or mass
Exodus of men leaving certain point
didn't we and Russia has taken over the
presidency of the U.N security Council
day what's your take on that it's quite
bizarre isn't it um but yes the whole
purpose unit Security Council compact
maintain security maintain peace combat
acts of international aggression and
they are in charge how does that work
it's 15 Nations there they rotate
through the presidency on alphabetical
basis
um but yesterday and part of this is the
nervousness about how Russia is going to
exploit this platform yesterday Russia
put out a brand new foreign policy it
was about
corralling a alignment of an alternative
block to Nato in other words an axis of
Evil possibly working with Iran North
Korea and China troubles China has made
very clear it wants to sit on their
fence it doesn't want to be party to
this but all the time what we can expect
to see is lavrov trying to exploit
Russia's presidency for their own agenda
expect some headlines in the next month